c'est un peu étrange cette logique qui
consiste à dire qu'il faudrait que les
que les riches ne payent pas c'est que
c'est curieux sachant que quand une
personne se retrouve sans travail
nous allons en vue quand même des
millions même des dizaines de millions
pendant l'année 2020 check raise hugo
vide n'en veut une situation où de
nombreuses personnes de très nombreuses
personnes se sont retrouvées privées de
leurs activités normales et s'il fallait
dire que ce sont que ce serait à eux de
payer leurs revenus alors qu'il n'a plus
d'activité est quelque chose qui est un
peu étonnant donc on est bien sûr une
logique universelle qui est de dire dans
une collectivité nationale
parmi tous les habitants de ce pays il y
à un principe de solidarité qui est très
clair déjà aujourd'hui avec la santé qui
est très claire aujourd'hui avec
l'éducation qui est très claire sur un
certain nombre de prestations et ses
mécanismes la concession qui soit
vraiment général plutôt que de faire ce
qu'on fait actuellement du bricolage
vous dis tiens vous voulez dans telle
situation vous avez dépassé si c'était
notre situation on a droit à cela et
ainsi de suite
et voici les règles ils font ceci et
voici pourquoi ils vont vous l'enlever
ainsi de suite non l'idée d'y voir
chaque être humain a besoin d'un socle
de revenus pour se nourrir tous les
jours tous les matins l'être humain a
besoin de savoir ce qui mettra dans son
assiette pour se nourrir ceci est une
règle absolue et donc il n'y a aucune
explication sur le fait ce qu'on peut
dire avez vous n'auriez pas le droit non
c'est juste pas possible
à entendre chaque être humain à la
nécessité de se nourrir chaque jour et
donc il faut une solution systématique
sans aucune condition à ce niveau
[Musique]